Yonegu-chan, I'm going to cook for my mom today I've decided I'll catch the catch
and I'll cook the day I promised
my mom, you should sit down and
leave it to me a3 You've
never made anything weird, have you?  I
'm proud that Boobu-chan is good at cooking.It's already disgraceful
to my mother if she keeps coming up with
wonderful IDs.TanoueThat's too much praise.
I have talent, so it
would be terrible if I drafted it.I have to build a
strong body to fight the heroes.
The rabbit meat is ideal for its low fat and high protein content,
but it has a strong
taste.
Second one in the pressure cooker
Baby made it for me, and the pot is convenient,
is
n't it?
It's just that, but it
's the magic I see.
Room is smart after all.
That's too much praise for my
father.I learned cooking in my previous life.It
's effective to pretend to be both wheels when infiltrating a party venue where a target to assassinate is.Bechamel sauce made with
goat's milk and butter beurmanne using it
is
pressured.  Add to the rabbit meat and vegetables cooked in a pot, and you have a
cream stew. You can get
all the nutrients you need for physical growth. You
're the perfect woman.